brings up manny machado on fire hitting
it 308 now with 11 homers and 28 runs
batted in
machado on the ground is short and
trevor will make the right play
grisham ran into an out especially where
he hit the ball he hit the ball
you know to his backhand side which made
it a really easy play
well he didn't lay off that and he
didn't touch it either very nice job by
antonio senzatel four gear with two down
and the padres second inning for josh
naylor
one-two pitch is a pop-up into
shallow left coming in is rymel he's got
it
and no damage done again here in the
second
no score back-to-back strikeouts and
that'll bring up garrett hampson
pitched by michelle had him going for
the chain swing at him strike three
he strikes out the side he's as sharp as
a razor literally
absolutely spectacular stuff from
michelle maez after two innings
leadoff man has reached for the padres
and here's trent grisham
the top of the order and this is a
broken bat
floater that's caught by charlie quick
throw back to first
black been on the move to fuentes and
they double up tourette
blackman caught it and then threw it off
his left foot and nailed the runner
and everybody stays where they're at
first and third with now one down
up the middle base hit come on down josh
fuentes tony walters will go first to
third
and trevor story comes through yet again
nine game hitting streak rbi number 19
for the rockies all-star shortstop
out here in the inning first and third
and the new pitcher is
luis perdomo here's the 1-0 with the
runner going from first and arnotto
lines it into center field grisham will
make the catch
could have an opportunity for double
play at first base the throw is in time
did the run score no it didn't both
runners tried to do something
and walters unable to tag and get from
third to home
prior to story being doubled up at first
base since has been outstanding so far
he's going to face
josh naylor luis terrence and trent
grisham
really nice play flips it over to josh
fuentes for
the out that is a wide shot fuentes to
the back another double play
good play by josh fuentes halfway home
one nothing
rocky two down runners at first and
second and brings up will
little myers that is a fair ball and
myers is out
jumping out is tony walters to grab it
aggressively he tags myers
and jace tingler is coming out to
dispute this
that's ted barrett lets him know that it
was a fair ball
and we'll also let the padres dug out to
know to be quiet
remember it's where the ball is touched
the ball may have hit and foul territory
and went forward because of the spin but
it's where it's touched
and in the opinion of home plate umpire
ted barrett he touched it in fair
territory
turns on this and into the shift it'll
be machado diving forward to make the
catch
that's normally a base hit and would
have continued the inning against pitino
but mandy
coming in a diving full extension coming
in grass top catch
i mean he's just been carving these
padres up
really the only guy that's had steady
success against him the guy at the plate
the nine-hole hitter terrence with two
singles
the only extra base hit was grisham
leading off the game with a double
and a marvelous performance tonight
the pitch swing and a miss senzatella
works a clean
seventh and he continues to shine
antonio senzatela with seven shutout
innings
and now it's second and third nobody out
down the line off the bag machado is
gonna throw home
too late two nothing colorado rogers
scores on the base hit by hanson one oh
on tap here
down the line fair ball mcmahon around
third stu cole's send him
and the throw will be cut off three
nothing how big was that not
[Music]
runners at the corners two down
kronerworth will line this down the
right field line it'll be a fair ball
rattles around in the corner tatis will
score machado is being waved around the
throw will go to second and it's a one
run game
myers lights it into center field for a
base hit kronerworth being waved around
there'll be no throw in the padres
they've tied it up three to three in the
eighth inning
will myers comes up big again at coors
field
daniel just five for his last 40 at the
plate
could raise those memories with one
swing here
and there it is base head left center
field hips it around
third and the rockies will win it daniel
murphy off the bench 4-3
colorado